ah
[Música]
según el medio independiente el diario
punto es alrededor del 65% de los
españoles vive bajo algún tipo de
restricción ya sea el cierre perimetral
de su municipio o la limitación de
horarios y de actividades comerciales
eso sí con escenarios parecidos cada
comunidad autónoma ha implantado medidas
dispares es por esto que hoy mismo el
ministro de sanidad se ha reunido con
las distintas comunidades autónomas para
implementar un plan que armonice los
criterios pero por otro lado también
recordemos que desde el punto de vista
judicial también ha habido discrepancias
el tribunal superior de justicia de aquí
de la comunidad de madrid tumbó unas
medidas que sí que avalaron tribunales
superiores de justicia de otras
comunidades autónomas es por eso que hoy
mismo también hemos escuchado un
magistrado de aquí del tsj de madrid
pidiendo al tribunal supremo al máximo
órgano judicial de españa' que sentará
jurisprudencia para también desde el
punto de vista judicial armonizar las
medidas en todo el país
[Música]
irlandés el primer país de europa en
realizar un segundo confinamiento
nacional esta vez de seis semanas debido
a un incremento de casos de coronavirus
a partir de este jueves todos los
negocios no esenciales cerraron sus
puertas y las personas solamente podrán
salir a hacer ejercicio si lo hacen no
más allá de cinco kilómetros de su casa
además los restaurantes y los bares
podrán hacer entregas a domicilio y eso
si las escuelas permanecen abiertas a
diferencia del confinamiento del mes de
marzo el gobierno de coalición irlandés
reconoció que estas nuevas medidas
restrictivas tendrán un fuerte impacto a
la economía pero que son necesarias para
detener la infección
irlanda tiene tasas de infección menores
a las de gran bretaña españa y francia-
pero su sistema de salud está saturado y
no es suficiente para atender a los
enfermos de coronavirus
[Música]
continúa disparada la curva epidémica en
italia esta semana se superó el récord
de los 16.000 nuevos casos positivos
diarios claramente la situación está
fuera de control en algunos territorios
en los cuales el número de infectados se
ha triplicado en los últimos 10 días una
situación frente a la cual varias
regiones italianas han decidido imponer
nuevas restricciones las regiones de
lombardía campania cerdeña y lazio han
decidido imponer el toque de queda en la
noche el jefe del gobierno italiano
giuseppe conté explicó delante del
parlamento del país que el objetivo es a
la vez asegurar la protección de la
salud pública pero sin sacrificar la
economía nacional paralelamente el
ministerio de salud ha anunciado el
inicio de una experimentación de
exámenes masivos de rápidos de
coronavirus a gran escala para lograr
rastrear más fácilmente los casos
positivos y frenar el contagio
[Música]